what do you think is like the best live
action out of a movie cuz that's hard
oh hi honestly one is for you Gintama oh
yeah double live action I was I've never
laughed that hard watching a live action
and like not even like I'm not talking
about like a Dragonball Evolution like
ironic laughing like it's genuinely
funny thief it's genuine it brings out
the Gintama spirit so [ __ ] well and I
don't know how the hell they did it
because you read a manga like in Tamil
watch anime like in telling you like
there's no way this can be live-action
yeah no [ __ ] way Lee you can't
translate this comedy into live-action
but they somehow did it allowed to do it
I'm like the casting was perfect the
cost reward tricks I've no idea even the
action scenes because the second half of
it goes into like the first story arc of
games yeah yeah yeah and concludes it
and I'm like wow this is actually like
really good CG really good choreography
and it's like very believable Gintama
movie like I would watch that again
that's how good I was pleasantly
surprised with the Jojo pop for maybe
really it was like I didn't like it yeah
he was like fine I didn't realize some
of the scenes they did pretty good I
mean that's that's that's the thing with
live-action anime movies right the bar
is so low that just yeah it is it's all
of these other shamelessly being
passable is like the best compliment you
can give an anime live-action I remember
watching the ghost in the shell' live
action and I remember how offensively
average it was yeah like it was like
like like I couldn't form an opinion in
it because I'm just like it's okay it's
like it the ghost Michelle was really
weird because it's like if you watched
it as a ghost in the show live-action it
was like a four out of ten yeah but if
he just watched it it's like if you just
thought like okay this is just a
standalone
like sci-fi complex you know I watched a
lead of the battle angel was like really
good and you tell you I forget that's a
yeah I think that's one of the best that
I like anime or manga movies we've had
really yeah I mean it was it was the
ending was just whack but I mean
everything up until the ending was
for me Aleta was very much like goes in
the show where is like a zit no I've put
it higher than ghosts in the show have
you read Aleta why I watch the show he's
read everything that's why I've watched
the movie right yeah I bet I bet if I
watch the manga I'd like yeah very much
like ghosts in the show he's the monk ha
ha but I read the manga I'd appreciated
but I'd like the mongrel if you it's
like ghost in the show right like people
who are fans of ghost in the show before
there was live-action were like that was
a [ __ ] adaptation of goats in the show
yeah Elite is exact same it's good as a
standalone movie but as an adaptation of
a leader
it was pretty weak but at least at least
the Hollywood ones are better than their
Japanese annotation watch the attack on
my god what's with the big like Nazis I
got invited by madman in Australia as
you go to the cinemas on the date like
know like you can bring a plus-one so I
brought my best friend yeah I feel like
a huge anime fan and we watched it and
we just kind of sat there as the credits
are rolling and I just looked around
like how was that my friends like I know
you got mean for free but I want my
money you know what I kind of have to
agree with you there man right
no because I like my cousin who I've
been trying to get into an life like
ages biggest normal you can kind of
think of and then I was reaching back
like I was like I was like recommending
attack on Titan because that's like one
of the perfect gay it's attack on Titan
and then he [ __ ] ends up watching the
attack on time live-action and he is
like yeah that wasn't very good I'm like
wow why you oh you were almost there you
were this close and now like now
whenever I recommend it's a Quinn site
I'm like no no no trust me the anime is
so much better he's like oh like is it
the same story but like yeah yeah hey my
son no but there's this character called
Levi he wasn't me in the live-action
because they couldn't pronounce his name
that's the reason why they cut him out
right oh really
the reason why Levi's not in the
live-action is because they were like
these are Japanese actors I don't think
they can pronounce the V sound and I'm
like you don't realize this was written
by a Japanese yeah yeah yeah people like
bad the reason why microwaves come with
instructions
they need a hand to hold oh my god you
what's the [ __ ] movie Oh how'd you
[ __ ] stay away from the movies though I
say from all our movies I think the only
one I should enjoy it is edge of
tomorrow which I didn't have one was
really good Tom Cruise Tom Cruise Tom
Hanks out yeah I didn't really cuz I
didn't even realize that was based on a
manga yeah all you need is kill just
like the edgiest title ever yeah all you
need is kill all you can remember it's
actually based off a novel that was
later adapted into a manga that was
written by about the Takeshi ah
illustrator for Death Note right right
right yeah which is also very good manga
so when I saw cuz like I picked up the
novel
walls in Japan because I was just like
all you need to secure [ __ ] yeah awesome
and I read it and the novel is really
good but then like when they were
promoting in the bookstore they were
like Tom Cruise movie coming out soon I
was just like oh no please please Tom
don't do this but of course I had to go
watch it cuz I'm like alright this is
gonna be pretty it's probably gonna be
[ __ ] let's go watch I was like oh good
I'll give you this one Holly was good
you did good you do you it was it was
one of the few films that I watched it
and I was like oh I gotta go read the
source material now and it was quite
different from the source material
wasn't exactly the same but that's how
you adapt a live-action movie in my
opinion gonna change some things if
there is something that is just if
there's a concept in a story that you
know will never work in live-action
don't put it in yeah it's so simple and
yet there are so many [ __ ]
productions and directors who are like
oh we can do it so we definitely
assassination classroom giant yellow guy
[ __ ] man CG will fix that is a weird
adaptation I I don't know why but I've
slowly started to find myself like
watching live action anime movies why
would you do this to us because it's
just gonna give me [ __ ] watching trash
she's secure it's just a guilty pleasure
for me now even if it's because I watch
the erase live-action as well and even
though I
like a raced Len that was on Netflix
right yeah but purely just because I was
like oh it's just it's it's the puffy
example of curiosity killed the cat
right because it's like I'm so curious
to be like this how could they possibly
adapt this and then I go into and I'm
like amazing I just wasted an hour and a
half just some anime adaptions you just
know gonna be [ __ ] yeah there's some you
watch for the train wreck but not all of
them like a race you don't need to watch
The Full Metal Alchemist live-action I
don't need to watch that to know it's
gonna be [ __ ] yeah that's the one I
that's the one thing I still haven't
know you know I'm gonna do you guys know
Idol alchemist isn't that good [ __ ] you
talk talks for myself miss ox what we
guys on the story run story
it's just awful I mean the only reason I
watch The Death Note one is because you
know I wha I know I wanted to be you
know able to help with the discussion on
Twitter I mean oh yeah I mean I got a
great video out of it but if you can't
yeah exactly right you can clown on it
it's great cuz everyone's gonna be
waiting for it but yeah you can't clown
the erased one cuz no one gives a [ __ ]
well that's why I didn't make a video
why watch you why why why I mean I've
done that I've done that with more I
think there are more anime live actions
that I haven't made a video on than ones
that I have made a video on just because
no one needs to know this is [ __ ] I just
need to know this because everybody
already knows it's [ __ ] like I didn't
have to make a video on the parasite
live action because everybody knew it
was gonna be [ __ ] but I needed to know
that it was gonna be [ __ ] and sure
enough and I found out that it was
absolutely go